Millions of of South Koreans will be on the move this weekend...
...as the country celebrates "Chuseok," the Korean thanksgiving holiday.
Chuseok is South Korea's biggest holiday, when Koreans reunite with families...
...to celebrate a good harvest and pay respects to their elders and ancestors.
And as with any holiday, there are lots of traditional foods prepared.
These foreign students have come to Korea to study the language.
They're also learning how to cook "songpyeon"...
...because they know how important it is to Koreans during Chuseok, which is Korean Thanksgiving Day.
Songpyeon is a type of rice cake.
It's made by kneading rice powder with hot water and stuffing the dough with healthy ingredients...
...like beans, sesame, chestnuts and other fillings
The songpyeon is steamed for about 20 to 30 minutes.
Now in the past, what was special about songpyeon was that it was steamed together with pine leaves.
But these days, that's no longer the case.
According to the cooking instructor,...
...pine needles are not as fresh as they used to be because of rising pollution.
After steaming, it's important to rinse the rice cakes in cold water.
Another special feature about the rice cake....
...is that the skin used to wrap the filling looks like a full moon.
But when it's cooked and ready to eat, it resembles a half moon.
It's common on the eve of Chuseok for family members to gather around the table...
...to make the most perfectly shaped rice cakes possible.
They say if you make pretty songpyeon, you will find a beautiful partner or have a beautiful baby.
But for these students, perfection was not in their minds.
Some even have their own ideas of what songpyeon should look like.
Whatever the shape, this rice cake will always be a traditional food...
...enjoyed by all Koreans during the Chuseok holidays.